tiens la parole est à madame catherine
vautrin si monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
enfin le gouvernement retrouve un
ministre en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
après plusieurs mois de vacances comme
si finalement cette vacance n'était rien
d'autre que le reflet de la déshérence
dans laquelle se trouve l'université
française un budget 2015 qui est un
budget en baisse de 5 millions pour
l'enseignement supérieur et encore après
intervention du président de la
république sur demande de la cpu la cpu
les élus s'étaient mobilisés devant
cette difficulté
si je parle des contrats de plan en
cours de signature ils sont
historiquement bas et finalement trop
souvent ce sont les collectivités
locales qui sont venu boucher les trous
pour remplacer les dotations de l'état
trop souvent manquantes et pour
permettre qu'en fin des projets puissent
sortir
ce sont donc une fois encore les
collectivités qui vont permettre
l'investissement
quant à l'autonomie des universités
berlin c'est très simple vous avez juste
bafouer le principe de l'autonomie des
universités puisque avec un hold up de
100 millions d'euros
vous avez stoppé la capacité
d'investissement des établissements les
plus vertueux
alors je pourrais continuer comme ça sur
l'état déplorable des campus peu
attractif pour nos étudiants voilà
l'inventaire qui vous attend monsieur le
ministre
alors au delà de nos voeux de courage je
voudrais vous dire qu il vous revient
vraiment de changer de paradigme
quelques questions simples
quel budget pour 2016 quel engagement
pour la clause de revoyure des cpr pour
la vie étudiante au delà des comités
théodule à quand des moyens d actions
concrètes
en un mot les collectivités sont prêtes
à vous accompagner
il reste un seul absent que va-t-il
faire c'est l'état nous attendons vos
réponses merci madame vautrin la parole
est à monsieur thierry mandon secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
madame la députée je veux vous remercier
de votre question qui finalement est
l'occasion pour moi de
d'abord saluer contrairement à une
partie de votre question les efforts qui
ont été faits ces dernières années en
matière de scolarité d'enseignement
supérieur et de vie étudiante
vous avez oublié dans votre question je
veux y voir un oubli tout à fait fortuit
l'effort considérable qui depuis le
début de son quinquennat a été fait pour
améliorer les conditions concrètes des
étudiants dans les universités je veux
dire l'effort en matière de vie
étudiante qui a absorbé à lui seul sur
plusieurs exercices
depuis 2012 plus de 300 millions d'euros
de crédits supplémentaires en
développement des bourses en
amélioration du système de scolarité des
étudiants et il me semble qu'au moment
où la démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur est un objectif partagé par
l'ensemble de la nation
cet effort qui a été piloté par
geneviève fioraso méritent d'être
saluées comme il comme il convient
évidemment avec ceux ci et là je partage
un certain nombre de vos interrogations
nous n'en sommes pas qui tu nous n'en
sommes pas qui d'abord de l'importance
vitale pour notre pays de l'effort de
recherche dans la durée cet effort a été
stabilisé depuis lé de quinquennat il
n'a pas bénéficié de surcroît de crédit
dans les difficultés budgétaires que
nous avons connu il n'a pas non plus été
l'objet de coupes budgétaires mais il
est absolument certain qu'au moment où
nous redéfinissons notre stratégie
nationale de recherche pour les années
qui viennent
les projections en termes budgétaires
des années d'aidés crédit qu'il nous
faudra trouver sont très importantes et
de ce point de vue là nous devons
relancer un certain nombre
d'investissements avec l'aide de
l'europe
avec l'aide de la seule agence nationale
pour la recherche et avec l'aide de leur
bref je ne doute pas que nous aurons
surtout ses bancs l'occasion dès les
prochaines semaines dans la discussion
budgétaire de trouver les moyens d'une
relance de l'effort indispensable pour
notre pays merci